hey guys welcome back to the second part
of the series where we talk about
biblical financial principles every man
must know in a previous video we talked
about never creating debt
never spending money you don't have on
things you don't need then we talked
about investing and then we talked about
creating a budget every month
now we're going to talk about a total of
eight things when it comes to biblical
financial principles
and number five is saving money
specifically saving money for the
unknown future
Proverbs 21 verse 20 says the wise store
of choice food and olive oil but fools
gold dares down
it is very important to save money for
the future
because you never know what the future
will hold right but also it is important
to save money for anything
unexpectedly that can happen at any time
and then you're not ready for it you can
do this by just putting aside a portion
of your income each month into a savings
account or an emergency fund look you
never expect a flat tire
but it happens in the same way you never
expect your water heater to burst but it
happens and those who do not plan for
the future they're just planning to fail
unexpected things will happen
and if you're not ready for it your
whole family you you'll be in trouble so
all you got to do is save your money for
those let's call it those flat tire days
so that when it happens you know you
have some money tucked away and it will
solve the problem and then you will
still have bread on the table Proverbs
21 verse 20 says precious treasure and
oil are in a wise man's dwelling meaning
he saves it but a foolish man devours it
you know there are always those who are
gluttonous
they are greedy for money and when they
have money they just want to spend it
they just want to live for the now
instead of thinking for the future
preparing for the future there are many
people out there who think like this
man I still have one hundred dollars
left what am I going to spend this on
instead of thinking man I still have 100
left let me save this for the future in
case I need it those who spend it
recklessly find themselves in need of
money time and time again
and they even get angry when people do
not want to help them
even when they ask their family if you
have a family member or a friend like
this then you should not help them
because you're actually helping them to
stay in that position and never learn
their lesson I think amen I have money
I'm just going to spend it and then when
I come to that point where they don't
have money oh I'm gonna ask John I'm
gonna ask Susan they will always help me
and then I keep on doing that they stay
in that
comfort zone
you will help them more if you don't
give them money because then they will
learn man it's my own actions that
brought me into this position now I'm in
trouble so I'm not going to do this
again
we have an Afrikaans saying
you made your bed so lay in it
if this is you and you just spend money
without thinking about it then you need
to know that there's always consequences
you will reap what you saw
if you sow not thinking just spending
all the time what do you think is going
to happen
you're going to have trouble you will
reap what you sow
but there's good news
the good news is that you can change and
that you can change today
let's move on to the next one
avoid get rich quick schemes Proverbs 13
verse 11 warns us wealth gained hastily
will dwindle
but whoever gathers little by little
will increase it
God's blessing will be upon you if you
work hard for the bread on the table for
your money if you walk within his will
what he wants you to do but not if you
want to join get rich quick schemes and
do you want to just try some shortcuts
to get ahead even bribing people in
business
his Blessing will not be upon you also
if you do the lottery or you go gambling
Isaiah 65 11 says but you who forsake
the Lord will forget my Holy Mountain we
set a table for fortune and fill cups of
mixed wine for Destiny I will Destin you
to the sword
and all of you shall bow down to the
slaughter because when I called you did
not answer
when I spoke you did not listen but you
did what was evil in my eyes and chose
what I did not the light in
trying to get rich quick often leads to
financial Rune because you're doing that
you're walking in your own will your own
desire slushy desires you're not walking
in God's will
we need to work hard for the money
that we receive you need to earn it and
then you can focus on making wise
financial decisions over time like
investing in stable long-term investment
opportunities
if you work hard for your money if you
walk within God's will and do what he
wants you to do with your life
he will bless you you don't want to make
the wrong decisions and not have God's
blessing on your life
that's the worst thing that can happen
to you
choose your friends wisely now you might
think Daniel what does this have to do
with Biblical financial principles
well everything
Dave Ramsey also talks about it he's
very wise and also well known talking
about biblical financial principles
and I watched some of his videos
especially when I was younger
and it's interesting just to hear what
he says about this but your friends will
influence you and that includes the way
you handle your money Proverbs 27 verse
17 says iron sharpens iron
and one man sharpens another
in one Corinthians 15 verse 33 says do
not be deceived
Bad Company ruins good morals
you see children learn the habits of
their parents they start to mimic you
and you when you look you just say oh
man he's doing the same thing that I've
been doing and I didn't even notice that
he learned this I didn't even teach it
to him because they watch you carefully
and it's the same thing when they go to
school they pick up things from their
friends wrong habits at times when they
come home and you realize man this is
something different I didn't teach where
did you learn this and you start that
conversation and when we grow up nothing
changes
truth is truth right so it doesn't
change we still pick up things from the
people we mingle with
from our friends especially who you
spend most of your time with
and this truth will never change bad
friends
will make you worse
and good friends will make you better
inspiring you to improve yourself if you
hang around with friends who make good
business decisions who plan ahead and
who educate themselves with good books
you will learn from them and want to do
the same and this will influence the way
you handle money
let's move on to the next one and the
last one
trust in and honor God with your
finances
ultimately our financial security and
our ultimate well-being comes from God
in the first place and it continues that
way especially for us as reborn
Christians as we grow spiritually in him
everything we do we do through the
spirit and that includes the way you
handle your money Proverbs 3 verse 5
says trust in the Lord with all your
heart and lean it on your own
understanding
in all your ways submit to him
and he will make your paths straight
by trusting God and following his
principles
that is how you can have true Financial
Peace and security and you will be a
better businessman with God
Proverbs 3 verse 9 says honor the Lord
with your wealth and with the first
fruits of all your produce then your
barns will be filled with plenty and
your Vats will be bursting with wine
let me ask you a question do you honor
God with your money
in this temporary world
you should use your finances to honor
God and use it to further his kingdom
because when you die and you stand
before him
what will he say to you
what have you done with the money that
I've given you
you see by giving generously
you can take part in God's work while
you are still here on this Earth and
also enjoy his blessings
2 Corinthians 9 verse 6. the point is
this
whoever sows sparingly
will also reap sparingly and whoever
sows bountifully will also reap
bountifully each one must give as he has
decided in his heart
meaning the Holy Spirit needs to lead
you
not reluctantly or under compulsion
for God loves a cheerful Giver
I can tell you this with confidence if
you prove that you can be trusted with
money then God might bless you more
financially
because he knows he can trust you
to use it responsibly and make wise
decisions to use it for his kingdom or
do you think God will just bless you
with money to spend it on your own
fleshly desires that you want to live in
luxury for just this short temporary
world to live in pleasure only for
yourself and you know this is exactly
why he does not bless certain people
with money when they ask him because he
knows this is what they will do
James 4 verse 3. you ask and do not
receive
because
you ask wrongly
to spend it on your passions
so God will bless you financially if it
is his will and if he knows that he can
trust you and first when he does bless
you you need to have Financial Security
yourself first before you can help other
people
Proverbs 14 21 says blessed is he who is
generous to the poor
so you need to help the poor but you
need to be wise in how you do that
because
the old saying of if you just buy a poor
man fish he'll expect you to do that
always but if you buy him the equipment
to catch fish himself you'll feed him
forever right
not only do you need to help the poor
you also need to help
the kingdom of God
what does that mean you can support
preachers missionaries and also
Ministries even online Ministries like
dlm people who rely on God to send them
the money to share the gospel the way
that he wants them to do it and God
usually do that through
his children Brothers and Sisters in
Christ that He blesses financially and
expects them to help those who do not
have normal work hours you know just
Monday to Friday but all that they do is
sharing the gospel that is their
full-time jobs
you know when Israel did not give back
to God he warned them God says in
Malachi 3 verse 8. will man rob God
yet you are rubbing me
but you say how have we robbed you
in your times and contributions
you are cursed with a curse for you are
rubbing me the whole nation of you bring
the full tithe into the storehouse
that there may be food in my house and
thereby put me to the test
says the Lord of hosts if I will not
open the windows of Heaven for you
and pour down for you a blessing until
there is no more need
and let me read this verse to you again
in the New Testament two Corinthians 9
verse 6 the point is this whoever sows
sparingly will also reap sparingly
and whoever sows bountifully will also
reap bountifully each one must give as
he has decided in his heart not
reluctantly or under compulsion
for God loves a cheerful Giver
and now verse 12 says for the ministry
of this service is not only supplying
the needs of the Saints
but is also overflowing in many things
givings to God
you know I just want to say this
whatever Church you are going to
I grew up in a church I saw my dad
working day and night people knocking
people phoning and then he has to preach
in the sermons and after the sermons
work with people psychological stuff
um help them to grow spiritually and
they were things at their homes I mean
the whole week
day and night
and I saw how much it costs to run a
church
to do all these things to put on the
lights and then still people complained
about giving money to the church
after all that work and listen carefully
you should not give money to fake
churches
to churches of false teachers
but you should help the True Church of
God to do its work to save Souls and to
help people grow spiritually in Christ
you know this is how the devil Works
people never complain about giving money
out when they go to see a movie or when
they go to see a show you know or a
concert they yeah sure here we go let's
go but they expect to go to the church
to get everything for free life-changing
sermons through the power of the Holy
Spirit and they are selfish
they don't want to give anything to God
why
that is your sinful fleshly heart
Paul actually talked about this directly
one Corinthians 9 verse 3 this is my
defense to those who would examine me
you see this is not something that just
is happening right now this is something
that was always there because humans we
always have our sinful flesh even as
Christians
and money is one of the things that
brings most of the trouble
Christians experience even in marriages
verse 4
do we not have the right to eat and
drink do we not have the right to take
along a believing wife
as do the other Apostles and the
brothers of the Lord and kefas or is it
only Barnabas and I who have no right to
refrain from working for a living
who serves as a soldier at his own
expense
who plans a Vineyard without eating any
of its fruit
or who tends A Flock without getting
some of the milk do I say these things
on human authority
that's not the law say the same
for it is written in the law of Moses
you shall not muzzle an ox when it
shreds out the grain is it for oxen that
God is concerned does he not certainly
speak for our sake
it is written for our sake because the
plow man should plow in Hope
and the thresher thresh in Hope of
sharing in the crop now he's been
working towards the point that he wants
to make and here it comes
if we have sown spiritual things among
you
is it too much if we reap material
things from you
if others shared this rightful claim on
you do not we even more
nevertheless we have not made use of
this right but we endure anything rather
than put an obstacle in the way of the
gospel of Christ
verse 13. do you not know that those who
are employed in the temple service get
their food from the temple and those who
serve at the altar share in the
sacrificial offerings
now listen to this
in the same way the Lord commanded that
those who proclaim the gospel should get
their living by the gospel
do you understand this even today there
are preachers out there churches
who want to follow Jesus Christ
pure hearts who want to share the gospel
through the Holy Spirit but they are
struggling to just have food on the
table because the church is not willing
to obey God and help them financially
so I want you to pray about the church
that you're going to
ask God God
am I giving enough
or should I give less
maybe I should give a little bit less
and maybe give to these people or that
people you know you should pray about
this because the Holy Spirit should lead
you there are some people who are angry
you know when the church talks about
this and so a lot of churches don't even
preach about this they are content with
food and clothing and they just try to
do the best that they can even though
they're struggling to keep bread on the
table
that's what I saw growing up with my
father
now on that note I just want to thank
you for those of you who partnered with
me and my team
who are helping us financially to keep
on sharing the gospel in a way that we
do
we would not have been able to do this
without your help so thank you
there are some of you that want to
partner with us monthly all the
information is in the video description
down below
we would love to expand our team to
share the gospel even more effectively
with all nations and all people
but if God is not leading you to help us
then don't do it you need to pray about
this first
maybe he wants you to help someone else
another church another missionary I
don't know you need to pray about this
so how else can you honor God with your
finances
by taking care of your own family
if your relatives are struggling
you need to help them especially if you
know that they are doing their best
working really hard making wise
decisions
and they're still struggling
because they might be praying to God to
help them and God is actually blessing
you and it's a test for you they want
you to help them so don't keep that
money selfishly just spending it on your
own desires while those around you are
struggling
1 Timothy 5 8 says but if anyone does
not provide for his relatives and
especially for members of his household
he has denied the faith and is worse
than an unbeliever
now if your attitude towards money is
right if you want to honor God
financially use the money that he gives
you responsibly then God will bless you
with your finances and you always need
to remember this Acts 20 35 in all
things I have shown you that by working
hard in this way we must help the weak
and remember the words of the Lord Jesus
how he himself said it is more blessed
to give than to receive
start the day and put these biblical
principles of how to deal with money
with your finances put it into practice
starting today
and rely on him
for provision
if you deal with money the right way
responsibly
using it for God's Kingdom for your
family using it wisely planning for the
future all these principles that we
discussed in these two videos
then God will be with you and he will
help you who will guide you and you can
just move forward with him
now always remember that life is short
so don't waste yours
bye guys